[Musique]
même pas mal
étirement qui casse-croûte et c'est
parti
Sonic c'est bien de vouloir changer le
monde je peux prendre le volant
crois-moi il arrivera un moment où tes
pouvoirs seront bien utiles
as-tu choisiras pas ce moment c'est le
moment qui de choisira ça me donne la
chair de poule dis donc tu as entendu ça
la télé
[Musique]
lors de mon voyage j'ai découvert la
source du pouvoir absolu
ça a l'air puissant il y a un moment que
c'était sur ma to do listes
ok alors voilà ce qu'on va faire
première phase on va aller taquiner
deuxième phase j'en ai vraiment aucune
idée
[Musique]
même pas mal
nos prévisions météo pour la journée une
avalanche d'aventure
[Musique]
retour à l'envoyeur
bref tu l'auras jamais mon pouvoir
j'ai l'air d'avoir besoin de ton pouvoir
Sonic je te présente Knuckles